le cancer est aujourd'hui la première
cause de mortalité en france
ils tuent environ cent cinquante mille
personnes par an et ce sont près de 300
mille nouveaux cas que l'on diagnostic
chaque année quand on nous parle du
cancer c'est souvent pour évoquer ses
causes comme par exemple le tabac ou
l'exposition aux rayons uv
mais on nous explique rarement ce qu'est
réellement cette maladie et par quels
mécanismes elle peut apparaître
aujourd'hui on va parler de ces
mécanismes mais aussi de l'évolution et
du traitement des cancers et pour cela
je me suis rendu à l'institut gustave
roussy
[Musique]
tout d'abord le cancer n'est pas
vraiment une maladie mais plutôt une
famille de maladie qui se caractérise
par une prolifération anormale de
cellules dans un tissu
alors voyons ensemble ce que ça veut
dire comme tous les êtres vivants nos
organismes sont fait de cellules
environ cent mille milliards pour un
être humain adulte les cellules
identiques sont regroupés en tissu qui à
leur tour peuvent constituer des organes
à tout moment de notre vie des cellules
meurent c'est normal et d'autres sont
créés pour les remplacer environ 200
milliards chaque jour
ces nouvelles cellules apparaissent par
division de cellules existantes
c'est le mécanisme de la mitose chez un
être humain adulte est en bonne santé il
existe un équilibre entre le nombre de
cellules qui meurt et celles qui sont
créées par mitose un cancer c'est quand
un groupe de cellules dans un de nos
tissus brice cet équilibre et se met à
se diviser de façon incontrôlée on se
retrouve alors avec un amas de cellules
dégénéré qu'on appelle une tumeur mais
vous savez peut-être que toutes les
tumeurs ne sont pas problématiques
certaines sont bénignes mais quand une
tumeur devient envahissante c'est là
qu'on parle de cancer
on entend tous presque chaque semaine
parler des causes du cancer et comment
on passe par exemple du tabac au fait
que des cellules se mettent à se diviser
de façon incontrôlée et bien pour le
comprendre
on va plonger au coeur des cellules et
s'intéresser aux mécanismes d'apparition
d'une tumeur cancéreuse
vous l'avez compris une tumeur c'est
quelque chose d'anormal c'est pas censé
se produire
la division cellulaire est un processus
très encadré très régulée et il existe
des dizaines de mécanismes qui sont là
pour la contrôler la surveiller et
maintenir cet équilibre entre le nombre
de cellules qui meurt et celles qui sont
produites par division cellulaire voyons
quelques-uns de ces mécanismes qui sont
là pour assurer que la prolifération des
cellules se fasse de manière contrôlée
tout d'abord une cellule naissance et se
divise et que quand on lui demande de le
faire quand elle reçoit un signal pour
ça et ensuite
al'inverse elle doit arrêter de se
diviser quand elle reçoit un signal
contraire et de toute façon même si on
ne lui dit pas une cellule n'est pas
censé continuer à se diviser
si elle sent qu'elle n'a plus placé
autour d'elle et puis même si une
cellule se met à défaillir il existe des
mécanismes de réparation de son adn
notamment qui sont là pour en quelque
sorte la ramener à la raison
si malgré tous ces réparations échoue il
existe encore un autre mécanisme qui
doit pousser les cellules défaillante à
se suicider c'est ce qu'on appelle la
pop toews
ça n'a rien d'exceptionnel et comme
situation le suicide programmé des
cellules qui ne fonctionnent plus
correctement est quelque chose de tout à
fait courant
cela concerne environ 60 milliards de
nos cellules chaque jour et si vraiment
aucun de ces mécanismes ne répond il
existe encore une protection
supplémentaire c'est le fait qu'une
cellule possède en principe une limite
sur le nombre de divisions successives
qu'elle peut subir entre 50 et 60
c'est ce qu'on appelle la limite de et
flic cette limite est dû au fait que
chaque fois qu'une cellule se divise
elle doit faire une copie de son adn
pour que ces deux cellules filles et
chacune le bon nombre de chromosomes et
cette opération raccourci légèrement
l'extrémité des chromosomes ce qu'on
appelle les télomères
quand les télomères sont raccourcis la
cellule ne peut plus fonctionner et
meurt bref vous voyez que normalement
une cellule ne doit pas se mettre à se
diviser de façon incontrôlée il existe
tout un tas de couches successives de
protection pour empêcher que ça n'arrive
mais évidemment il y a tellement de
division chaque jour dans un organisme
que régulièrement dans des cellules un
ou plusieurs de ces mécanismes se
mettent à ne pas fonctionner si un seul
de ces mécanismes des rails ça n'est pas
forcément très grave parce que les
autres sont là pour le rattraper mais si
par malheur un jour dans une cellule il
y a trop de ces mécanismes de protection
qui sont inactifs
cette cellule peut échapper à la
régulation se mettre à se diviser de
façon incontrôlée et créer une tumeur
mais qu'est ce qui fait que certains de
ces mécanismes peuvent se mettre à ne
plus fonctionner et bien c'est une
affaire de jeunes derrière chacun de ces
mécanismes de contrôle il y a des gènes
et si un mécanisme se met à dérailler
c'est que l'un des gènes qui le pilote
est altérée
[Musique]
ce qu'on constate c'est que pour qu'une
cellule se mettent à proliférer
anormalement et à peut-être causer un
cancer il faut qu'un certain nombre des
gènes qu'elle porte et qui contrôle sa
division se trouve abîmée on peut donc
dire que en un certain sens le cancer
est une maladie génétique
alors attention généralement quand on
parle de maladies génétiques on pense
aux maladies héréditaires une maladie
héréditaire c'est quand vous possédez un
gène défectueux qui vous a été passée
par l'un de vos parents ou les deux et
qui se trouve là depuis votre première
cellule dès la fécondation puisque quand
une cellules se divisent l'adn et
répliquer et bien le gène défectueux
sera présent dans toutes les cellules de
votre corps
la différence entre le cancer est une
maladie héréditaire c'est que dans le
cancer les gènes défectueux ne sont
présents que dans certaines cellules
je vous ai dit que lors d'une division
l'adn et répliquer mais cette copie
n'est pas toujours parfaite
il peut y avoir des minuscules
changements au niveau d'une cellule d
erreur de copie des mutations et ses
mutations sont aléatoires donc
différente d'une cellule à l'autre je
l'évoqué tout à l'heure il existe un
mécanisme de réparation de l'adn qui
permet de corriger les mutations mais on
sait que ce mécanisme n'est pas efficace
à 100 % et l'adn d'une cellule subi en
moyenne dix mille lésions par jour et
donc à un moment donné dans une de nos
cellules
il peut y avoir une mutation qui
invalide un des mécanismes de contrôle
de la prolifération cellulaire alors on
l'a dit tout à l'heure s'il ya un
mécanisme qui déraille ça n'est pas
forcément très grave parce que des
mécanismes de contrôle il y en a
plusieurs
sauf que si une cellule se retrouve avec
une mutation cette mutation va être
recopier lors de sa division et elle va
passer à toutes ses cellules filles et
un jour sous l'effet du hasard
l'une de ses descendantes peut subir une
deuxième mutation qui va faire tomber un
deuxième mécanisme de contrôle et ainsi
de suite les mutations s'accumulent et
un jour la faute à pas de chance
une des cellules se retrouve avec
suffisamment de mutation pour échapper à
tous les mécanismes de contrôle et elle
se met alors à se diviser de façon
incontrôlée et bien sûr le drame c'est
que toutes les cellules qu'elle produit
en se divisant sont identiques à elle
donc elle aussi se mettent à se diviser
de façon incontrôlée et c'est comme ça
qu'on se retrouve avec une tumeur
vous comprenez que pour qu'une cellule
se mettent à devenir potentiellement
cancéreuses il faut que plusieurs
mutations s'accumulent au cours du temps
comme c'est un processus aléatoires
chaque cancer aura un profil génétique
différent qui va dépendre bien sûr du
tissus ou d'organes dans lequel il se
produit mais aussi de la séquence des
mutations qui longe
dre mais on retrouve des régularités des
séquences de mutation qui semblant
favoriser d'autres par exemple il existe
un gène appelée p53 dont on constate
qu'il a subi une mutation dans plus de
la moitié des cancers
ce gène semble impliqué dans plusieurs
des mécanismes de contrôle dont on a
parlé et on surnomme parfois le gardien
du génome
[Musique]
on l'a vu ce qui engendre un cancer
c'est une succession une accumulation de
mutation c'est pour ça qu'un cancer a
rarement une cause ou une origine unique
c'est un ensemble de causes héréditaires
environnementales liées à notre
comportement qui vont favoriser
l'apparition de mutations ces mutations
s'accumulent les unes après les autres
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour une de nos
cellules se retrouve avec une
combinaison perdante de mutation alors
quand je dis que c'est rarement une
seule cause il ya évidemment des
exceptions
il ya des circonstances par exemple
l'exposition à de très fortes doses de
radioactivité qui peuvent provoquer
tellement mutation qu'elles vont
engendrer un cancer à elle seule
il ya aussi quelques facteurs
héréditaires qui vont favoriser
l'apparition de certaines mutations
la plupart du temps ça n'implique pas
qu'on développe un cancer à coup sûr
mais il existe par exemple un gène
appelé brca1 dont on sait qu'il
multiplie par 6 ou 7
le risque d'avoir un cancer du sein chez
la femme vous en avez peut-être déjà
entendu parler dans le cas d'angelina
jolie
mais même quand il y a des
prédispositions génétiques l'apparition
d'un cancer reste un phénomène aléatoire
qui dépend d'une combinaison de facteurs
liés à notre environnement et à nos
comportements pour se prémunir du cancer
ça paraît clair tout ce qui favorise les
mutations c'est à dire tout ce qu'ils
agressent notre adn est mauvais le tabac
certains produits chimiques l'alcool et
oui faut pas l'oublier
l'alcool est un cancérigène avéré mais
aussi l'obésité l'amiante
l'exposition au soleil et notamment aux
uv la radioactivité les rayons x
certains agents infectieux comme par
exemple papillomavirus un mauvais régime
alimentaire avec trop de charcuterie par
exemple etc
mais attention ça n'est pas mettons la
butte saucisson qui va causer un cancer
à lui tout seul
par contre il peut participer un peu à
l'accumulation de mutations dans des
tissus qui serait au contact avec des
taux trop élevés de sel comme par
exemple dans l'estomac pour se tenir au
courant de ce qui peut favoriser
l'apparition d'un cancer
il existe un organisme appelé l'iarc l'
agence internationale pour la recherche
sur le cancer qui classe les différentes
substances et comportements il existe
cinq classes pour les arcs la classe 1
c'est cancérigène avéré pour l'homme
comme le tabac ou l'alcool
ah oui au fait on entend parfois
cancérigènes ou cancérogènes on
considère que c'est synonyme dans la
classe 1
outre le tabac et l'alcool on trouve
aussi le plutonium la noix de bétel le
fait d'être ramoneur les rayons du
soleil ou l'utilisation d'une lampe à
bronzer
la classe 2 ah c'est cancérigène pro
abl c'est à dire qu'on a des preuves
limitées de son caractère cancérigène
pour l'être humain mais qu'on a pu le
montrer de manière avérée par exemple
chez l'animal dans la classe de à
on a le glyphosate le fameux composé
actif du roundup certains composés à
base de plomb la malaria mais aussi les
boissons servies à une température
supérieure à 65 degrés le travail de
nuit ou le fait d'être coiffeur ou
barbier dans la classe 2b
on a les cancérigènes possibles pour
lesquelles on a des soupçons mais peu de
preuves
le nickel les champs électromagnétiques
le dioxyde de titane l'aloe vera bien le
fait d'être pompier la classe 3 c'est
celle des produits dits inclassable pour
lesquels on n'a pas de preuves
suffisantes ni dans un sens ni dans
l'autre
on y trouve la caféine le paracétamol
les champs électriques et aussi le dit
nitrose au peintre méthylène tetra mines
vous savez pas ce que c'est bon
moi non plus et enfin la classe 4 c'est
celle des produits classés probablement
non cancérigène c'est à dire qu'on
dispose de preuves solides du fait
qu'elle n'augmente pas le risque de
cancer
et bizarrement dans cette classe on
trouve qu'une seule substance le
caprolactame alors soyons clairs ce
classement en cause beaucoup de
confusion par exemple il ya peu de temps
la viande rouge transformée comme par
exemple saucisson ou bacon a été mise en
classe un cancérigène avéré
est ce que ça veut dire qu'en mangeant
trop de bacon je vais finir par
développer un cancer
alors non il ya une chose essentielle à
comprendre sur le classement l'iarc
c'est qu'il est basé sur le degré de
certitude pas sur le niveau de risque
vous sentez bien qu'entre le bacon et le
plutonium qui sont tous les deux en
classe 1
il ya une différence de risque mais pour
les deux on a la certitude scientifique
qu'il joue un rôle donc ils sont en
classe 1
prenons un exemple fictif pour mieux
comprendre si demain on prouve avec une
certitude scientifique que la
consommation quotidienne de plus d'1 kg
de truffes augmente le risque de cancer
de 0 001 % et bien la truffe ira en
classe 1
même si le risque est très faible même
si l'exposition aux truffes est
négligeable
si on a la certitude que les faits
existent aussi faible soit-il ce sera la
classe 1
ce qui compte pour le classement l'iarc
c'est le niveau de certitude pas
l'ampleur du risque
personnellement je trouve ça assez
maladroit comme façon de communiquer
parce que du coup on retrouve dans la
classe un pêle-mêle des choses très
risqué peut risquer des choses très
répandue est peu répandu et ça brouille
le message pour le grand public d'autant
que bien souvent dans les médias les
différences sont occultés et on parle
simplement de
classé cancérigène sans préciser de
quelle classe on parle avéré probable ou
juste possible garder ça en tête la
prochaine fois que vous lirez un gros
titres sur le fait que tel ou tel truc a
été classé cancérigène
maintenant qu'on a passé en revue les
mécanismes d'apparition du cancer et les
causes qui peuvent en être à l'origine
je voudrais revenir sur ce qui se passe
ensuite l'évolution des cancers
on l'a vu aussi incroyable que ça puisse
paraître au départ d'un cancer il y a
une seule cellule une qui a accumulé
suffisamment de mutation pour échapper
aux contrôles la prolifération
cellulaire se mettre à se diviser de
façon incontrôlée et engendrer une
tumeur
je l'évoqué au début et c'est très
important une tumeur ne fait pas
forcément un cancer il existe des
tumeurs bénignes
l'exemple le plus connu ce sont les
grains de beauté mais il ya aussi les
verrues ou certaines tumeurs qui peuvent
être de taille importante mais sans
gravité pour l'organisme ce qui fait
qu'une tumeur peut devenir ma ligne
c'est-à-dire cancéreuses c'est notamment
sa capacité à continuer à bénéficier des
ressources de l'organisme en les
détournant pour cela il faut que la
tumeur soit notamment capable de faire
apparaître des vaisseaux sanguins qui
vont continuer à l'alimenter en oxygène
et lui permettre de proliférer on
appelle ça l'angiogénèse l'autre
mécanisme qui peut caractériser
l'évolution des cancers ce sont les
métastases une métastase c'est quand une
cellule cancéreuse arrive à s'échapper
de son tissu d'origine pour trouver
refuge dans un autre organe et y causer
une nouvelle tumeur
cette migration se fait généralement par
le sens où la lymphe et il existe des
tissus qui vont plus naturellement être
susceptibles de recevoir des métastases
mais il faut retenir que d'une part tous
les cancers n'en font pas et d'autre
part même en cas de métastases un cancer
reste de son type initial un cancer du
poumon qui fait des métastases dans le x
reste un cancer du poumon par un cancer
du foie
je l' ai dit en introduction le cancer
est aujourd'hui la première cause de
mortalité en france
cette mortalité diminue mais elle a
diminué moins vite que celle des
maladies cardiovasculaires qui était
autrefois la première cause de mortalité
malgré tout la probabilité de survivre à
un cancer est très différente d'un type
de cancer à l'autre
le tableau que vous voyez ici vous
montre trois choses le nombre de
nouveaux cas chaque année de différents
types de cancer la mortalité associée et
le taux de survie qui représente la
proportion des patients qui sont encore
vivants cinq ans après un diagnostic
vous voyez par exemple que le cancer le
plus fréquent est celui de la prostate
mais qui
tu beaucoup moins en proportion que
d'autres cancers il est temps maintenant
de parler des traitements possibles du
cancer et des développements de
recherche associés tout d'abord on l'a
dit le cancer est plutôt une famille de
maladie donc il faut pas s'attendre à ce
qu'un jour on trouve un médicament
unique universel chaque cancer est
différent d'une part parce que les
tissus impliqué varient mais aussi parce
que la succession mutation qui a
engendré la tumeur est potentiellement
très différentes d'un cas un autre
chaque cancer un profil génétique
particulier qui nécessite un traitement
personnalisé et adapté
le premier type de traitement qu'on peut
envisager c'est la chirurgie il s'agit
simplement si l'on peut dire de faire
une ablation de la tumeur
le gros problème c'est d'être sûr
d'absolument tout enlever on l'a dit une
seule cellule qui défaillent peut
engendrer une tumeur donc si l'opération
chirurgicale ne laisse ne serait ce
qu'une seule cellule cancéreuse
cela peut compromettre la guérison pour
s'assurer de sa le chirurgien qui enlève
une tumeur doit généralement couper
largement dans la partie saine du tissu
ce qui n'est pas toujours possible ou
souhaitable autre type de traitement
qu'on peut utiliser la radiothérapie
elle consiste à envoyer des rayons x sur
la tumeur dans le but de la détruire
on l'a vu une des caractéristiques des
cellules cancéreuses c'est qu'elles ont
perdu une partie de leur capacité à
réparer leur adn
la radiothérapie exploite en quelque
sorte cette faiblesse puisque les rayons
x ont pour effet justement d'induire
encore plus de dommages dans l'adn et
donc de détruire la cellule enfin
dernier traitement classique c'est la
chimiothérapie
l'idée consiste à donner aux patients
des médicaments qui vont spécifiquement
attaquer les cellules cancéreuses
mais comment on fait pour être sûr
qu'elles vont attaquer uniquement ces
cellules là et pas les autres cellules
les cellules saines et bien on utilise
des substances comme des sels de platine
qui vont spécifiquement endommager l'adn
des cellules qui se divisent beaucoup
une fois de plus on exploite le fait que
les cellules cancéreuses ont perdu une
partie de leur capacité à réparer leur
adn mais également le fait que ces
cellules malades se divise en moyenne
beaucoup plus fréquemment que les
cellules normales
le problème de ces traitements par
chimiothérapie c'est qu'ils ont tendance
à avoir des dommages collatéraux sur des
cellules qui naturellement se divise
souvent par exemple les cellules du tube
digestif ou les follicules de cheveux
d'où la perte des cheveux qui est
l'effet secondaire le plus connu des
chimiothérapies
quand on le peut on essaye d'utiliser
ces traitements en combinaison par
exemple chimiothérapie et radiothérapie
mais il faut bien retenir qu'il n'y a
pas de combinaisons miracle qui serait
tout le temps supérieur aux autres
la recherche d'un traitement efficace
dépend du profil génétique du cancer et
ils varient d'une personne à l'autre
même pour un même type de cancer le
choix du meilleur traitement reste une
décision de spécialistes prise en
concertation
une petite précision au passage à ce
stade de la vidéo vous êtes rendu compte
que le cancer est une maladie
incroyablement complexe et protéiforme
inutile de dire que les remèdes de
charlatans basée uniquement sur du jus
de citron ou la méditation donc peu de
chances d'être efficace
pour terminer je voudrais vous faire
découvrir une nouvelle famille de
thérapie qui est peut-être en train de
révolutionner la manière dont on traite
certains cancers il s'agit de
l'immunothérapie et pour en savoir plus
j'ai été interrogé les chercheurs de
l'institut gustave roussy
[Musique]
professeur caroline robert vous êtes
chef du service de dermatologie ici à
l'institut gustave roussy
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer le
principe de l'immunothérapie alors
l'immunothérapie comme son nom l'indiqué
c'est la thérapie
le traitement par l'action sur le
système immunitaire
c'est très différent des traitements
comme les chimiothérapies ou les
thérapies ciblées où on va aller essayer
de détruire directement le cancer ici on
va se servir de nous cellules du système
immunitaire
nos lymphocytes de cellules qui
normalement doivent nous protéger par
exemple vis-à-vis des infections virales
ou bactériennes
donc ces lymphocytes on va essayer de
leur faire comprendre qu'il faut rejeter
les cellules cancéreuses
merci est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser quels sont les différents modes
d'action possible de l'immunothérapie
en fait l'immunothérapie qui a marché
qui est vraiment a fait faire un pas en
avant gigantesque c'est quand on a pensé
à bloquer des mécanismes régulateurs
négatif c'est un peu compliqué mais en
fait notre système immunitaire c'est un
peu toujours comme ça dans l'organisme
il y à des systèmes positif et des
systèmes négatif parce qu'il faut que
les réponses biologiques aient lieu mais
faut pas qu'elle s'emballe trop donc il
ya toujours des freins et en fait il ya
des freins aussi pour l'activation du
système immunitaire est assez récemment
on a découvert les molécules et les
récepteurs qui était vraiment en jeu
dans ces freins et le premier qu'on a
découvert s'appelle c'était l a4 et se
fait molécule elle peut être bloquée par
un anticorps qu'on injecte et si on
bloque c'est l a4 on bloque son
interaction avec son contre récepteur
une block un blocage donc comme on
bloque un blocage on libère l'action du
système immunitaire et sur quels types
de cancer c'est immunothérapie sont
efficaces les premiers résultats
positifs on les a eus avec un anticorps
anti c'était à l'a4 dans le cadre des
patients atteints de mélanome
métastatique mélanome c'est un cancer de
la peau qui parfois peut être grave
quand ils donnent des métastases et cet
anticorps anti c'était à l'a4 a été le
premier traitement en fait qui a
démontré sur cette population de
patients avec une maladie très grave
qu'on pouvait vraiment prolonger de
façon significative la survie des
patientes et des patients qui survivent
est très très longtemps grâce à ce
traitement pour vous dire ce qui se
passe dans les autres cancers en fait on
a ouvert la voie le deuxième cancer qui
a été démontré comme sensibles à
l'immunothérapie c'est leur affaire du
poumon les différents types de cancer du
poumon est là aussi ces médicaments
maintenant sont sur le marché pour
traiter différentes formes de cancer du
poumon est maintenant bien il ya
beaucoup d'autres concerts qui se
montrent sensibles à l'immunothérapie
avec des sensibilités variable et est ce
qu'il existe d'autres types de
récepteurs qu'on peut cibler avec ses
immunothérapie l'être vivant c'est
extrêmement complexe on a des tas de
signaux positifs et négatifs et bien sûr
qu'il y en a d'autres et il y en a
d'autres qui sont déjà à l'essai tout
seul et en combinaison avec les
immunothérapies qui sont déjà prouvé
comme l'efficace donc on est vraiment
entré dans l'ère des combinaisons de
traitement combinaison d'immunothérapie
séquence d'immunothérapie est-ce qu'on
utilise parfois c'est immunothérapie en
association avec d'autres thérapies donc
maintenant évidemment on essaie de
combiner avec d'autres immunothérapie en
combine des immunothérapies entre elles
mais on essaye aussi d'utiliser toutes
nos autres arme anticancer les
chimiothérapies
les thérapies ciblées des molécules qui
agissent directement sur la mort
cellulaire
même la radiothérapie est ce qu'on
essaye de faire maintenant c'est une
médecine vraiment plus intelligente où
on regarde les choses en dynamique
c'est-à-dire que les choses sont pas
fixés le système nos systèmes
biologiques is évolué au cours du temps
les cancers sont sensibles après
développent des résistances et nous on
ne voit pas ce que les cancers parfois
près contre le traitement et après se
mettent à ne plus répondre ou ne
répondent plus sur les différentes notes
as tu as de la même façon donc nous on
essaye avec les chercheurs les équipes
de recherche de faire des prises de sang
et de même très élevé
des fragments des biopsies on appelle ça
de tumeurs au fil du temps pour
comprendre ce qui se met en place comme
résistance et pour déjouer ces
résistances et pour être capable
d'utiliser les armes qu'il faut au bon
professeur caroline robert merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à mes questions
aujourd'hui vous voyez que grâce à la
recherche
on arrive à mettre au point de nouveaux
traitements qui élargissent encore
l'arsenal thérapeutique dont on dispose
pour traiter les différents cancers mais
il ya encore beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir
pas seulement du côté des traitements
mais aussi de la compréhension des
causes et des mécanismes fondamentaux
d'apparition des cancers tenez un simple
exemple pour éveiller votre curiosité
puisque l'apparition d'un cancer est
liée à la défaillance d'une cellule un
jour dans notre organisme
on devrait s'attendre à ce que plus un
organisme contient deux cellules plus
les de risques de développer un cancer
mais bizarrement un animal comme
l'éléphant est beaucoup moins sujet aux
cancers que l'homme
comment est ce possible le mystère a
peut-être été levée dans une étude parue
en octobre 2015
vous vous souvenez du gène p53 celui
qu'on appelle le gardien du génome et
qu'on retrouve muté dans plus de la
moitié des cancers et bien les éléphants
en possède 20 copies contre une seule
pour les humains et donc dans une
cellule d'éléphant même si une ou
plusieurs copies du gène p53 sont mutés
et donc défaillante
il en reste encore plusieurs qui sont
fonctionnels même si ça n'explique pas
tout cela montre qu'il existe encore
bien des choses à comprendre au niveau
fondamental sur les moyens dont
disposent les organismes pour se
prémunir naturellement des cancers voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui merci
d'avoir suivi cette longue vidéo une
vidéo un petit peu particulière assez
différente de ce que je fais d'habitude
et qui n'aurait pas été possible sans
l'aide de plusieurs personnes que je
dois vraiment sincèrement remercier tout
d'abord elodie grelier et antoine
courant de l'institut des sciences du
cancer ce sont eux qui n'ont en fait
ouvert les portes de l'institut gustave
roussy qui m'ont permis de rencontrer le
personnel
et puis aussi surtout de faire relire
mon script par les chercheurs et les
médecins de l'institut
ce qui évidemment sur un sujet complexe
comme le cancer était quelque chose
d'indispensable pour moi donc merci
beaucoup à eux deux et puis vous aurez
remarqué aussi que dans cette vidéo
l'image était quand même un peu
différente de ce que je fais d'habitude
et ça c'est grâce à raphaël thiollier
key est réalisateur et qui m'a proposé
de venir travailler avec moi sur ce
projet donc merci au pouvoir afin si ça
vous intéresse vous pouvez aller voir ce
qui fait je vous mettrai le lien
son portfolio dans la description voilà
d'ici là je vous souhaite de passer un
bel été je pense qu'il aura quelques
petites vidéos dans l'intervalle mais je
sais pas encore exactement comment si
vous voulez des nouvelles de la chaînes
vous pouvez retrouver de toute façon par
les canaux habituels facebook twitter et
puis je vous retrouve de toute façon
dans quelques semaines pour des
nouvelles vidéos voilà bientôt